Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. In unserer 198. Ausgabe dieses schönen Formats wollen wir mal wieder auf Europas Top-League gucken. Naja, nicht auf alle, die Premier League fehlt heute. Aber wir haben viel schöne Sachen für euch dabei. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir wollen mal wieder auf Europas Top-Fußball gucken. Zur Premier League haben wir heute keinen Experten, keine Expertin gefunden. Aber es wird uns dennoch allen nicht langweilig werden. Denn wir haben ja unter anderem Alexis Menuge hier für die Ligue 1. Hallo, Alexis. Schön, dass du hier bist. Dann Mario Rieker zur Serie A. Hallo, Mario. Ja, ich freue mich, dass ihr hier seid. Ebenso wie Nils Kern zu der Liga. Ach ja, es ist wirklich eine schöne Tradition. Jedes Mal, wenn wir aufnehmen, frage ich mich, warum wir das nicht noch öfter machen. Aber ich weiß, es liegt allein in meiner Verantwortung. Also, wir wollen heute sprechen über Spanien, Italien und Frankreich. Wir haben ein übergeordnetes Thema. Ich würde gerne in allen drei Ligen mal auf den Abstiegskampf blicken. Aber ich nehme an, Nils, dass ihr auch wieder Themen mitgebracht habt. Was liegt denn bei dir, Nils, zum Beispiel im Argen, auf dem Herzen? Was sollten wir heute unbedingt ansprechen?
Abstiegskampf ist ja immer ein interessantes Thema. Man kann auch ein bisschen noch mal reden darüber, dass Real Madrid so ein bisschen zur Meisterschaft spaziert, dass irgendwie Sevilla nicht so richtig will. Auch der Atletikligo der Meister hat so ziemlich die schwächste Saison bisher. Und dass Simeone seit Simeone da ist, das könnte man noch mal kurz anreißen. Aber Abstiegskampf gibt es schon auch einiges.
Okay, ich sehe schon, so richtig krass verändert haben sich die Themen in der Liga da nicht zum letzten Mal. Aber so ist das halt auch manchmal. Mario, was bietet uns denn die Serie A an?
Ja, auch da ist schöne Kontinuität gegeben im Vergleich zu den Folgen zuvor. Es ist immer noch ein super, super spannender Meisterschaftskampf. Und womit man in Italien auch immer gut beraten ist, wenn man ein wenig VAR-Schelte betreibt. Das war auch vor allem gerade wieder am vergangenen Spieltag viel Wildes dabei, was so aus der Schiedsrichter-Ecke kam, was viele Schlagzeilen besorgt hat.
Was heißt denn Erben auf Italienisch? Weißt du das zufällig?
Ich bin da leider, meine zwei Bubble-Kurse sind da noch nicht so weit fortgeschritten. Aber ich glaube, wenn man sich mit Alex Feuerherd oder Klaas Riese da mal sich paar Entscheidungen aus Italien angucken würde, da wäre wahrscheinlich einiges Kopfschütteln mehr angebracht, als es dann doch vielleicht in anderen Liegen der Fall ist. Das ist zumindest so eine gefühlte Wahrheit, die ich immer so habe, wenn ich mir das angucke, was da für Entscheidungen getroffen oder sogar daneben halt nicht getroffen werden.
Das setzt manches in Perspektive. Das ist jetzt dann doch schade, dass wir in der Stelle nicht die Premier League mit dabei haben. Man kann sich mit niemandem so gut über Up-Sides-Entscheidungen streiten, selbst wenn sie aufgelöst werden am Bildschirm wie mit Premier League-Fans. Das ist einfach ein schönes Thema. Alexi, was hat die Ligue 1 heute für uns auf dem Tisch?
einmal die Champions League bestritten haben. Auf den ersten Blick denkt man sich, die würden überhaupt keinen Punkt holen in der Gruppenphase. Aber ich erkläre euch, warum diese Mannschaften sogar ins Achtelfinale eingehen könnten. Und vielleicht noch ein Thema, dass die Deutschen, piece auf nübel, überhaupt nicht zum Zug gekommen bzw. relativ disziplinlos wirken von Boateng bis Baxler.
Okay, Alexi, damit hast du mich gekauft. Damit will ich unbedingt gleich anfangen. Was ist da los mit den Deutschen in der Liga?
Wir fangen an beim Promenitesten von von allen. John Boateng, Weltmeister 2014, fast an den beiden Ikonen, zehn Jahre an der Säbener Straße gewesen, kommt nach Lyon im Sommer, weil er eigentlich sollte nach Sevilla. Wäre Kunde von Sevilla nach Chelsea gewechselt, aber als sich dieser Transfer zerschlagen so musste, wurde Boateng von Peter Boss nach einer Stunde am Telefon überredet, um nach Lyon zu wechseln. Es fing alles gut an, er hat sofort das Wort ergriffen in der Kabine. Aber sehr schnell musste er feststellen, es läuft in Frankreich anders als in Deutschland. Wenn man so Anweisungen an einen jungen Spieler gibt, dann hört dieser junge Spieler nicht wirklich zu. Das war noch in München anders. So ist der deutsche Nationalspieler mehrfach ausgeflippt. So sehr, dass mittlerweile sein Trainer auf ihn verzichtet. Das ist die Frage, ob er jemals wieder das Niveau trinkt oder ob er überhaupt eine Zukunft bei der UL hat.
Was heißt denn ausgeflippt? Da gibt es ja auch eine historische Branche Rumbauer. Deswegen muss man da doch mal präzisieren.
Ich glaube schon, es wurde schon angreiflich im Training mit Gimarech, der mittlerweile für 50 Millionen Euro im Januar zu Newcastle gewechselt ist, immer wieder Wortgefechte, auch mitten im Spiel. Das hatte man schon gesehen in der Hinrunde mit seinem Kapitän Du Bois und danach mit dem Jungspieler Cherki, ein Ausnahmetalent, der aber auch nicht gern zuhört und keine oder ungern Anweisungen bekommt. Deswegen wurde es immer wieder sehr angespannt in der Kabine. Zuletzt gab es wieder Rabereien, sodass Jérôme für ein Spiel gesperrt wurde von seinem Trainer. Also nicht im Kader berufen und seitdem hat er sich leicht verletzt, sodass er nicht zum Zuge kommt. Aber es ist schwer zu glauben, dass er in der kommenden Saison noch bei Jérôme spielt. Vor allem, wo jetzt Jérôme auf Platz zehn steht und womöglich gar nicht europäisch vertreten wird.
Nils, Mario, habt ihr davon gehört –ich hör gerade zum allerersten Mal davon, dass Jérôme Boiteng solche Probleme hat in der Liga.
Ja, mir auch nur, ich dachte, der wäre ganz gut gestartet, ganz gut angekommen, aber interessant, was man alles erfährt hier.
Ja, wirklich, ich hab auch nur die Schlagzeiten von seiner Anfangsphase im Kopf, wo hier gut angekommen, geht gleich vorne weg. Alexi, liegt das auch irgendwie dran, dass es sportlich so schlecht läuft oder ist es tatsächlich dieses, ich sag mal, Kabinen-Habitus, dass man da halt sich auch als Altersspieler das sehr, sehr persönlich nimmt, auch wenn dann ein junger nicht spurt?
Ich glaube, es steht eben gewaltig, dass die Einstellung bei diesen Spielern nicht stimmt und dass die Ergebnisse auch nicht stimmen. Er war nach Lyon gekommen, um diese Mannschaft wieder in die Champions League zu führen. Es gibt nur noch einen Weg, dass Lyon die Europa League gewinnt, wird aber schwer genug bei der Konkurrenz und bei dem Niveau, dass Lyon zeigt seit Wochen keine Konstanz. Also ich glaube schon, dass er enttäuscht ist vom Potenzial, dass diese Mannschaft nicht ausschöpft, obwohl die Bedingungen da sind. Also ein Top-Stadion und Top-Bedingungen, um dort glücklich zu werden. Aber scheinbar ist er vielleicht sogar mit seiner Wahl nicht zufrieden, überhaupt in Lyon gewichselt zu sein. Sein bester Freund der Kabine, Shakiri, war schneller wieder weg, als er überhaupt angekommen ist. Und deswegen keine einfachen Zeiten für ihn und er hat nur einen Vertrag bis 2023.
Aber die Schuld ist dann quasi klar auf Boateng verteilt, weil du sagst, die jungen Spieler würden nicht auf ihn hören. Er wurde jetzt gesperrt. Also ich will jetzt gar nicht Handgreiflichkeiten oder so etwas kleinreden. Dafür bin ich auch logischerweise, wie man gehört hat, nicht tief genug drin im Thema. Aber kann man das irgendwie erklären, warum er sich da fast schon isoliert in der Mannschaft?
Ich glaube, wie es das mit der Sprache zu tun hat, weil die meisten können schon Englisch. Da kann man ein bisschen Französisch. Ich meine, er hatte letzte Saison noch sieben Franzosen der Kavine in München, also mehr als ein Million gerade gefüllt. Aber wie gesagt, das ist schon ein Weltunterschied, wenn du von einem Mythos Bayern zu einer Mannschaft der Lyon wechselst, wo zwar eine gewisse Vergangenheit vorhanden ist, siebenmal Meister in Folge gewesen, ohne Scheich, ohne Millionen oder Milliarden. Das hat nicht mal ein paar Rechtsanwohner geschaffen und wird auch nie schaffen. Und deswegen ist es für ihn schon auch ein Kulturschock gewesen. Die Einstellung, wie man sich auf die Spiele vorbereitet. Vielleicht hat er auch Peter Borz überschätzt, weil der niederländische Trainer, der schon in Dortmund und Leverkusen genug Probleme hatte, sich auch bei Lyon nicht durchsetzen und auch vor dem aussteht. Ich meine, Platz 10 Spieltage vor Schluss ist eine sehr schlechte Bilanz. Bei diesem Spielerpotenzial, Lyon müsste eigentlich immer auf dem Podium stehen, ist nicht der Fall, sodass der Niederländer auch in der kommenden Saison nicht mehr in Lyon sein sollte. Wenn Juve Heinkirch zu lautem Archivsfeld nicht nach Lyon wechselt, dann wird auch Boateng nicht mehr dort sein.
Okay, nicht mit Schaich. Also ohne Schaich ist man zwar Champions League Meister geworden, meine ich, aber mit Juninho. Das ist fast genauso. Wunderschöne Freistöße. Ach so, ja, stimmt. Genau. Das kam ja danach auch noch. Siehst du, das habe ich gerade ganz ignoriert. Ich habe natürlich nur den Spieler Juninho so richtig genau verfolgt. Oh Gott, da will man gar nicht wissen, was hier in Deutschland los wäre, wenn das so wäre, dass ein Star aus einer anderen Liga oder ein sehr großer Spieler kommt und dann den Jungen Anweisungen gibt und sich mit den handgreiflichenkeiten leistet. Nils, gibt es irgendwas Vergleichbares in der Liga, woran dich das erinnert oder ist das, was für sich stehend ist?
Wenn es jetzt darum geht, Disziplinenlosigkeiten und immer mal Problemchen hier, würde mir jetzt auch aktuell vom Wochenende noch ein Nabil Fekir einfallen. Der ist ja von Lyon gekommen, ist so bei Betis so ziemlich der Star, hat da jetzt auch am Wochenende mal wieder ein gutes Spiel gemacht, aber mal wieder rote Karte gesehen. Ich glaube, das war jetzt schon seine achte rote Karte oder so bei Betis in 100 Spielen oder so. Der ist da immer mal für sowas gut, aber er spielt ja trotzdem, er springt ja eigentlich trotzdem Leistung. Betis steht im Pokalfinale, also da hat man irgendwie die Balance, mit die ihm hinbekommen. Aber so ein richtiges Sorgenkind, der dann auch irgendwie sich verletzt meldet und nicht ist der Astme jetzt in einer Liga nicht so bekannt.
Das heißt auch, dass er immer wieder provoziert wird bei Betis, weil er in der Tat der beste Spieler von Betis ist und eine Riesen-Saison spielt und dass Betis noch auf allen drei Wettbewerben verteilt ist, ist auch dank seiner Konstanz und herausragenden Leistungen.
Ich muss noch kurz korrigieren, es war jetzt fünfter Platz im 108. Spiel, ich hatte es mir schon extra notiert. Er spielt eine Riesen-Saison, genauso mit Canales, da ist Betis für furiosen, mutigen Offensivfußball bekannt. Noch sind sie auf allen drei Hochzeiten, aber mittlerweile merkt man auch die Doppelbelastung oder die Dreifachbelastung sogar. Da gab es in den letzten Wochen auch ein paar Niederlagen, auch in wichtigen Spielen gegen Sevilla, gegen Villarreal. Von dem her mal schauen, jetzt auch erstmal wieder ohne Fick hier in der Liga.
Aber wir können ausschließen, dass es an Lyon liegt, ja? Also es ist nicht der Pöbelklub Lyon, der jetzt hier die Disziplinlosigkeiten anschließt.
Da würde ich zumindest sagen, da gibt es dann ein anderes gutes Beispiel, auch Lyon nach Schule, würde ich mal sagen. Da kommt ja Karim Benzemaher, der ist ja aktuell der beste Spieler der Liga, hat jetzt schon 32 Tore in der Saison bei Real Madrid erzielt. Das ist so sein persönlicher Rekord, das Gesicht der Liga oder der Saison mittlerweile. Er wird wohl seinen ersten Peschischi, seine erste teuerige Krone gewinnen. Also es gibt auch sehr, sehr gute Beispiele von Olimpique. Nicht nur den Naby Fekir, der ja trotzdem noch gut spielt.
Manche sagen sogar, er ist der beste Stürmer der Welt, weil er hat in 16 Minuten drei Tore gegen Peschischi gemacht und Messi zwei Tore in der gesamten Saison in der Liga.
Aber habe ich das gerade richtig gehört, Nils, Bancermain hat noch nie die Teuerjäger-Krone in Spanien gewonnen?
Er ist ja in den Spuren von Cristiano, von Messi gewandelt, auch Luis Suarez hat die ein-, zweimal die Teuerjäger-Krone gewonnen, Benz Maas jetzt seit 2009 in der Liga, da wird es mal Zeit, dass er das mal holt, er ist ja jetzt auch schon seine 34 Jahre alt, also hat er sich dann auch mal verdient, das Ding mal zu gewinnen.
Verrückt, okay, das hätte ich nicht so gedacht. Wenn wir bei Betis sind, da hätte ich noch eine kurze Nachfrage. Wie wird denn in Spanien oder jetzt unter den Betis-Fans dieses erste Spiel gegen Eintracht Frankfurt gesehen, bei dem ja die Eintracht noch höher hätte gewinnen können als nur in Anführungszeichen 2 zu 1?
Also der Glaube ist bei Betis auf jeden Fall noch da. Da redet man auch von einem Verein, der ja eine kleine Ausnahmesaison spielt, der auch getragen wird von der Mannschaft. Auch wenn man das jetzt vielleicht im Hinspiel, dass das da jetzt nicht zu einem Sieg gereicht hat oder so. Aber da ist auf jeden Fall der Glaube noch da. Manuel Pellegrini hat die Defensive wieder ganz gut hinbekommen. Man war auch vor ein, zwei Jahren noch die Schießbude der Liga. Das passt mittlerweile vorne, egal ob Boca, Iglesias, Villain-José spielen oder eben Fekir, Canales, Juanmi hat einige Tore gemacht. Da geht schon einiges zusammen. Ich glaube, in Frankfurt wird das auf jeden Fall spannend am Donnerstag. Der Glaube ist da, weil man diesen großen Rückenwind endlich mal wieder Pokalfinale hat. Ich glaube erst seit 2003 oder so, dass man da auch große Teams eins ausgewischt hat und immer noch den Traum vom Finale auch zu Hause hat im Stadion, vom Erzrivain natürlich, vom FC Sevilla ist ja das Europa League-Finale. Aber da ist schon extra Motivation dabei.
Okay, wir kamen ja von den Disziplinenlosigkeiten, Mario hat die Serie A noch was zu bieten. Heute geht es an die taktisch geilen Analysen ran, heute will ich die Juicy-Details aus den Ligern.
Ja, ich muss aber dann danach gleich nochmal zurück zu Alexi, weil der Name Traxler ist ja auch gefallen, ich wollte da gerne noch mehr hören, was da noch alles passiert ist. Disziplinenlosigkeiten der Serie A, hauptsächlich gerade tatsächlich Trainer. Ich habe leider noch keine Obta-Recherche dafür angeschränkt oder sowas, was so im Vergleich in den anderen Ligen und zur Serie A die Trainer an Platzverweisen kassieren, aber in den letzten Wochen immer wieder sieht man eben den Co-Trainer da am Anfang stehen und das ist eben nicht wie in anderen Ligen, weil dann der Chef-Coach positiv getestet wurde, sondern weil sie reihenweise rote Karten kassieren von den Schiedsrichtern. Also Mourinho war dabei, Gasperini war schon wieder zweimal nicht dabei.
Der hat schon zwei Platzverweise gesehen oder wurde für zwei Spiele gesperrt?
Naja, in der Vorrunde war er auch schon einmal raus, aber die sind da sehr salty unterwegs gegen die Schiedsrichter und gefallen sich dann teils auch Insagi jetzt, nur in Interviews danach, das ist dafür dann noch nicht gesperrt worden, aber gefallen sich teilweise auch sehr in der Opferrolle, also Insagi hat also ein bisschen versucht, den Mourinho 2.0 zu machen, wo ja bei der Chose sind ja auch immer alle anderen schuld, zuletzt auch sind es ganz gerne die eigenen Spieler, die selber schuld sind. Und, ah, gut, das ist eine Geschichte, die hat aber nicht so ganz groß viel Aufsehen erregt, es gab einen sehr jungen Spieler, Zalefsky von der Roma, der hat jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal gespielt, das ist auch schon aber wieder über ein Dreivierteljahr her, da ist er mit einem bekannten italienischen Rapper irgendwo im Club unterwegs gewesen und das ist dann ein Instagram-Video aufgetaucht, wo der Rapper drüber gesprochen hat, dass hier und da heute Abend ordentlich was konsumiert wird, auch durch Nase und Chose gucken wir an den Jungen, wir machen jetzt Party. Das Video war dann ganz, ganz schnell gelöscht und es soll auch alles nicht so gewesen sein, wie es aussah.
Klar.
Aber sonst eher in der Historie, also wir hatten ja alles, wir hatten Balotelli, Raja Nengolan, hat auch immer tatsächlich nicht nur Wasser getrunken, hat man sich so erzählt, wenn es mal auch an Tagen vor dem Spiel irgendwo dann vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit hatte im Hotel.
Was macht denn Arturo Vidal so? Hält der sich am Rahmen?
Der hält sich weitestgehend im Rahmen und spielt relativ durchschnittlich Fußball.
Also quasi die Bayern-Version von ihm? Die etwas langweilige Bayern-Version. Womit wir bei Julian Draxler wären, bei welchem Attribut auch immer ihr das jetzt sehen wollt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Was wolltest du zu Julian Draxler wissen? Weil Alexis den vorhin auch irgendwie angesprochen hatte, als es um die disziplinlosen Deutschen gab. Oder ich habe das da falsch gehört.
Nein, das ist schon richtig, aber es ist ganz anders als Boateng, also keine Handwerklichkeit. Man weiß ja, wie ruhig und diskret er ist. Aber man wird ihm schon vergeworfen in Paris, dass er die Mannschaft nicht weiterbringt, dass er einfach stagniert seit Jahren. Und das betrifft ihm, Grosavard oder Icardi, die allesamt verlängert haben in den letzten Monaten, um Jahre. Und die keine Rolle spielen in dieser Mannschaft. Also natürlich sind da auch die Vereinsbosse zum Teil schuld, weil sie ganz große Namen hören oder holen, aber ohne, dass diese Spieler in der Lage sind, in einer Mannschaft zu funktionieren. Und Draxler ist halt seit jetzt mittlerweile fünf Jahren in Paris, hat sich keineswegs verbessert. Wird hoffentlich nicht von Hansi Flick berufen jetzt, morgen oder übermorgen, weil er einfach auch die Deutschlandmannschaft in dieser Verfassung nicht weiterbringen würde. Im Gegensatz zu Kehrer, der auch nicht so oft spielt, aber zumindest ein bisschen öfter als Julian und dafür auch auf verschiedene Positionen eingesetzt werden kann. Und ich glaube eh, wenn Kehrer bis zum Saisonende jetzt nicht mehr spielen würde, wäre er trotzdem bei der WM-Karte dabei, weil er einfach vielseitig ist und das gefällt Hansi Flick. Aber die Situation ist bei Julian Draxler anders. Ich bin gespannt, ob er über die Saison hinaus bleibt, weil mit dem neuen Trainer, egal wer es ist, wird er wahrscheinlich keine große Rolle spielen. Aber er fühlt sich sehr wohl in Paris, er bekommt ordentlich Geld jeden Monat auf dem Konto und er sieht keinen Grund, den Verein zu verlassen. Er ist nicht besessen, nicht ambitioniert genug und das ist schon eine große Verschwendung.
Aber inwiefern kann man ihm das dann auch vollständig zum Vorwurf machen? Denn klar, auf der einen Seite will ich natürlich auch immer einen Spieler haben, der irgendwie brennt und dann doch wieder auch unzufrieden mit seiner Reservistenrolle ist. Aber immer wenn ich ihn jetzt auch mal gesehen habe und da kann ich das dann auch nachempfinden, wenn er dann irgendwie der 86. 87. eingewechselt wird und Chock dann so lethargisch ausfällt, dann klar, denke ich mir auf der einen Seite, Junge, jetzt zeig doch mal was. Auf der anderen Seite kann ich auch voll den Gesichtsausdruck nachempfinden, wie du so, ja, wieder komme ich für die letzten zwei Minuten und jetzt soll ich hier nochmal was machen und sonst legt dir keinen Wert auf mich. Aber dafür sehe ich auch zu wenig, die Gare spiele, wie viel Zeit bekommt er denn überhaupt sich zu zeigen oder zeigt er sich schon im Training gar nicht oder wie ist da so der Eindruck?
Ja gut, die drei Monster da vorne, also Monster, also das wird ein Messium nehmen, wo Monster sind oder ehemalige Monster, sagen wir, oder ehemalige gute Spieler, dies ist auch schwer, die rauszunehmen. Das ist klar, dass Bocaetino eh keinen Mut hat, einer von beiden auszuwechseln, das hat man in Madrid gesehen, wo beide in der letzten halben Stunde eigentlich nicht mehr auf dem Platz waren, zumindest geistig. Und da ist der Tagsläufer auch viel zu spät, aber er bringt eh nichts, so wirklich von der Körpersprache, von seinem auch schwierigen Potenzial, bringt er eh viel zu wenig seit vielen Jahren. Und das wissen auch die Entscheider nur, warum verlängert er dann noch drei Jahre im letzten Sommer nach einem Vier-Augengespräch mit Bocaetino. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Argentinier ihm viele Einsatzzeiten versprochen hat. Das war wahrscheinlich auch vor der Verpflichtung von Messi, aber auch er kann eigentlich auch verschiedene Positionen spielen, also als Nummer 10 oder auf dem Pflügel. Sogar als hängender Spitze hat er schon gespielt in Paris, aber trotzdem, wenn er auch so wenig zum Einsatz kommt, dann hat das auch mit seiner Einstellung im Training zu tun. Man weiß ja, dass er nicht der Fleißigste ist. Das war er noch nie und wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr werden. Aber er gehört zu dieser deutschen Spielergeneration, wie Schürrle früher oder wie Goetze, wie Reus. Diese Generation nennen wir in der französischen Generation Choussons, also die immer Hausschuhe anhaben, keine Fußballschuhe. Die haben alle super Potenzial, machen aber viel zu wenig draus. Und dazu gehört auch Lion Wachsler.
Ich finde, jetzt steht auf einmal ein Elefant im Raum und der guckt dich, Alexi, und dich, Nils, an. Nämlich dieses Champions-League-Spiel zwischen Real Madrid und PSG. Ich glaube, darüber müssen wir sprechen. Nils, wenn du magst, dann darfst du mal anfangen und die spanische Sicht auf dieses 3 zu 1 von Real wiedergeben, mit dem es Real wieder mal geschafft hat, weiterzukommen und für PSG mal wieder Schluss war in der K.o.-Runde der Champions League. Erzähl mal, wie das in Spanien aufgefasst wurde.
Da ist natürlich eigentlich immer noch Euphorie angesagt. Das war ja nicht nur ein dramatischer Sieg, weil Real Madrid nach 0-1 hinspielt. Nach 0-1 Halbzeit stand noch 3-1 gewonnen. Das war ja auch die Ausgangssituation mit PSG, der Scheich-Club, der sich eher gegen die Super League positioniert hat, wo sich Alkela Ify klar auch in die ECA reingekommen ist und immer gesagt hat, im Papier wird bleiben. Diese ganzen Thematiken kommen dazu. Und dass da eben Real Madrid auf die Art und Weise PSG noch aus dem Wettbewerb wirft innerhalb weniger Minuten und zehn Sekunden nach dem 2-1 fällt das 3-1. Da sind ja in Benabeu alle Dämme gebrochen. Da waren natürlich alle Titelbettas erstmal voll. Und dann ist natürlich auch weiter Euphoriewelle jetzt Real Madrid drauf. Ich war gestern noch beim 3-0-Sieg auf Mallorca dabei. Auch da hat man schon gemerkt, Benzema hat schon weiter Lust zu treffen. Aber das war schon –also ich kenne viele Sosios-Mitglieder von Real Madrid. Die haben selbst gesagt, die haben schon 5000 Spiele live gesehen von Real Madrid, auch Champions League-Finals, etliche. Aber das ist eines der top fünf emotionalsten Spiele, was sie jemals erlebt haben. So besonders war das die Art und Weise, wie der Real Madrid wirklich den PSG ist ja all in gegangen im Sommer, hat sich groß verstärkt natürlich mit Messi, Ramos und so weiter. Und dann, um dann doch im Achtelfinale auszuscheiden, beim verhassten Madrid das MVP verpflichten wird, das hat schon einige Geschmäckle.
Alexi, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Aber weil du es kaum hast gesehen, oder?
Überhaupt nicht. Nach einer Stunde war völlig klar, dass Paris weiterkommt bis zum 1-1. Wir haben das Spiel so was von einem Griff gehabt, genau wie im Hinspiel. Hat alles gepasst, taktisch, von der Einstellung war echt alles perfekt. Und dann kommt der Fehler von Donnar Roma und auf einmal brechen alle Dämme. Auf einmal ist diese Mannschaft auseinander. Keine Reaktion, ganz schlechte Körpersprache, Marquinhos, der eigentlich Weltklasse ist, sein schlechtes Spiel in seiner PSG-Zeit, also in den letzten zehn Jahren, absolviert. Wenn er schon mit Winkler Süle verglichen wird und sogar als schlechter Süle gilt, dann stimmt ihm das nicht beim Brasilianer. Bei allem Respekt, aber klar, wie eine Katastrophe aller PSG, das ist mittlerweile Tradition, das war für manche Akteure sogar schlimmer als die damalige Gere Montada in Barcelona, weil man in Barcelona ausgeschieden ist wegen Dennis Eideckin. Und dieses Mal war der Schiedsrichter auf der Höhe. Und so auszuscheiden...
Ja, aber sehen das wirklich nicht alle so? Ich habe gehört, Leonardo würde da ganz, ganz leicht, und Alke Laifi war es vor allem, der ja direkt in die Schiedsrichterkabine gestürmt ist. Ich glaube, der würde dir sanft widersprechen an dieser Stelle.
Sehen Sie ruhig, aber mir wäre es auch lieber, dass beide den Verein verlassen, damit endlich mal der Schenkwunder die Schimmel zu geben, weil mir diesen zwei Clowns, wenn die eh nicht schaffen, klar machen zu. Klar, dass beide auf den Schiedsrichter losgehen, das war einfach eine Schande, dass die immer wieder auf den Schiedsrichter zugehen, sobald die verlieren, das gehört sich einfach nicht. Und es wurde auch relativ brutal in den Katakomben, sodass Alke Laifi wieder nix von der UEFA gesperrt werden könnte. Aber klar, da wird die ganze Politik und das ganze Konzept von QSE, von Kaka Sports Investment, haben nur ein halbes Jahr vor der Heim-WM einen kompletten Fall gestellt. Wie geht es weiter im Sommer mit welchen Spielern, mit welchem Trainer, mit welchem Sportdirektor? Die Fans haben eh es satt von dieser Politik, weil sie sich mit dieser Mannschaft nicht identifizieren. Die haben nur Stars, die an sich denken, die nur da sind, damit der Verein viele Trikots verkauft, aber nicht in der Lage ist, die Champions League zu gewinnen. Wie ihr seht, es gibt sehr viele Baustellen. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie Paris Saint-Germain zum Saisonauftakt im August aussieht. Der letzte Saisonviertel wird für Paris Saint-Germain extrem lang sein, nur noch zehn Liga-Spiele. Paris wird Ehemäster, aber lustlos. Ich glaube, das wird auch die meisterfeieraller Zeiten.
Ja, Salzburger Meister schaffen darf man da nicht vergessen. Das muss man erstmal toppen. Aber das stimmt, aus allen Wettbewerben ausgeschieden, da gibt es jetzt nicht mehr viel zu holen für PSG. Und Nils in Madrid wird jetzt vermutlich bald ein Stuhl im Museum stehen, der den David Alaba zum Juven hochgehalten hat. Wobei ich gesehen habe, ich glaube, Kammerwinger hat sich auch noch ein Stuhl geschnappt. Was ist das mit den Stühlen im Bernabéu?
Ja, es war dann Millitao, der dann auch nochmal... Ja, es war einfach, Alaba hat es danach selbst in einem Interview mit Spox, glaube ich, gesagt, von wegen da bei so einem dramatischen Spiel, die Art und Weise, da kann man schon mal durchdrehen und die sind da alle so über die Ordner gestolpert, die Spieler, wie sie zu den Fans gelaufen sind. Dann fliegen natürlich ein paar Stühle durch, durch die Luft und dann hat er einfach zugepackt. Er ist ja auch ein bisschen David Alaba, so dieser Typ, was der der Mannschaft bringt, einfach so vom Herzen her, wie er redet mit den Spielern, wie er anfeuert, wie er auch beim Torjubel immer irgendwie einen Mitspieler ins Gesicht klatscht. Das ist schon, da bringt er schon auch eine ganz besondere Note, wo vielleicht Sergio Ramos ein bisschen mehr so, der ja mehr auf sich gezogen hat und da irgendwie mehr so im Vordergrund stehen wollte, da Alaba wirklich nochmal auch ein Teamplayer hat wirklich die Lücke sofort ausgefüllt und ist mit Militao da ein ideales Abwehr-Duo. Also dafür, dass man Ramos und Varan verloren hat, merkt man aktuell gar nichts. Man hat irgendwie die beste Abwehr seit 11 Jahren mit irgendwie nur 0,73 Gegentoren pro Partie. Das ist sensationell und Alaba ist einfach sowohl mental wichtig als auch spielerisch. Und ja, wenn er sich immer mal wieder in den Stuhl packt, kann er das gerne machen, ist natürlich jetzt ein neues Symbol, wie einst irgendwie die Papierkugel in –wo war das? Bremen oder Hamburg. Einfach legendär geworden.
Warum habe ich nur das Gefühl, dass Mario gerade lächeln muss? Weiß ich nicht.
Schön, dass in dem Zusammenhang hier nochmal die Papierkugel hochkommt. Da muss ich immer schmunzeln.
Legendär halt.
Ja, aber wirklich legendär. Also das war die Champions League. Mario, ich will jetzt unbedingt wissen, was der VHA so toll macht in Italien, dass du ihn uns schon so dermaßen angepriesen hast. Wir hatten das schon häufiger jetzt in Ligatour-Segmenten, dass es seltsame Fehlentscheidungen gab. Einmal erinnere ich mich auch, leider habe ich jetzt gerade den Namen des Schiedsrichters vergessen, der aber das Tor aberkannt hat, weil er den Vorteil nicht hat ausspielen lassen und sich dann direkt danach noch entschuldigt hat. Das hat uns Christian damals erzählt, als er hier war. Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder los?
Ja, also die Aktion, das war ja irgendwie auch alles gut. Das hat eben ja dann selbst Milan nicht so übel nehmen können, weil er wirklich wie ein Häufchen Elend dann nachher auch zu ihnen in die Kabine gekommen ist, so was man erzählt bekommen hat. Jetzt war es aber wieder der Fall, dass wir ein Wochenende hatten, wo die Serie A-Schiedsrichter wieder –also ich glaube, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass es ein italienisches Grundproblem ist. Das gibt auch viele Schiedsrichter aus anderen europäischen Ligen, auch aus Deutschland, die prinzipiell bei den Spielern glaube ich nicht ganz so sympathisch rüberkommen aufgrund ihres Auftretens. Das kann dann nach außen selbstdarstellerisch wirken oder wie auch immer. Da kann sich jeder seine Meinung selber bilden, glaube ich, wenn der Schiedsrichter dann bei der Arbeit zuschaut. Aber das war jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende wieder mehrfach der Fall. Und es gab eine ganz entscheidende Situation im Spiel zwischen Torino und Inter. Als Torino das Spiel auch verdienterweise hätte gewinnen müssen, lang 1-0 geführt. Alexis Sanchez hat erst in der dritten Minute der Nachspielzeit dann noch das Unentschieden für Inter mitgeholt. Aber auch schon beim Stand von 1-0 hätte es einen klaren Elfmeter für Torino geben müssen. Da wird Bellotti gefault von Ranocchia. Also er setzt zum Schuss an und er schlägt ihm das Standbein, das sich gerade auf den Boden setzen wollte, um dann mit dem anderen Fuß abzuschließen. Dann wird ihm im Spiel selbst weggetreten, lässt er es weiterlaufen und dann ist es aber eine Unterbrechung. Man sieht auch, dass der VAR es checkt. Das wird sich angeguckt und ich glaube, das haben auch Carsten und Christian begleitet bei uns auf der Sohn. Du siehst die erste Zeitlupe und es ist ein Elfmeter. Es gibt keine zwei Meinungen darüber. Es ist ein glasklarer Elfmeter, er spielt den Ball nicht. Das Beinstellen unten ist ursächlich für den Fall. Das benutzen die Kuliners Erben ja auch ganz gerne das Wort. Das ist wirklich ursätzlich für seinen Sturz. Er macht da auch nicht zu viel draus. Belott ist es auch nicht der große Faller eigentlich. Dann dauert es 30 Sekunden, dann dauert es 60 Sekunden. Und dann denkst du schon so, warum gucken sich das so lang an? Dann gucken sie sich nochmal aus einer Perspektive an, die völlig falsch war. Es gab zwei Perspektiven, die waren sehr, sehr gut. Und dann, der Schiedsrichter hat es sich nicht mal selber angeschaut. Eigentlich ist es eine Sache, die in Italien auch sehr viel häufiger gemacht wird als in der Bundesliga. Ist das auch eigentlich bei vermeintlich klaren Entscheidungen, sich trotzdem nochmal der Feldschiedsrichter das anguckt, glaube ich. Das soll einfach auch irgendwie dessen Autorität stärken. Aber er guckt es sich nicht selber an und auf einmal pfeift er, winkt halt auf weiterspielen und niemand hat die Welt verstanden. Und da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt eben, wo ich mich dann auch selber immer so krass reinsteigern könnte, dass ja auch, wenn viele immer sagen, dass es argument, dass es fairer macht, geht bei mir gerade bei solchen Aktionen dann völlig verloren. Denn klar, es werden viele, viele Fehlentscheidungen dadurch ausgemerzt durch den VHR. Keine Frage, auch bei Upside-Sachen. Wobei ich inzwischen auch gar nicht mehr weiß, ob ganz oft auch nicht gepfiffen wird, weil man weiß, man hat den noch im Hintergrund. Aber es wird wirklich halt auch für die Fußballfans und auch für die Spieler von gerade in dem Fall dann für Urino danach so unverständlich, wenn Sachen, die dann dadurch hätten ausgemerzt werden können, nicht richtig entschieden werden. Und dann muss man sich schon die Frage stellen, was das eigentlich überhaupt noch soll.
Und ist das auch der Tenor, mit dem in Italien darüber geredet wird? Darüber hängt vielleicht noch ein größeres Thema, vielleicht aber auch nur mich, für mich vor Urteilsbehafteten Deutschen. Schiedsrichter in Italien waren ja auch schon mal in einem anderen Zusammenhang ein Thema, weil Karl Tschupoli und –ich weiß nicht, ob er da jetzt von Bestechung reden kann, zumindest von zweifelhaften Entscheidungen. Wurde da im Schiedsrichterwesen danach eigentlich irgendetwas verändert, dass so was nicht wieder vorkommen kann? Oder ist das jetzt –also ich fühle mich auch gerade sehr unwohl, weil ich Angst habe, ein ganz schlimmes Vorurteil gerade hier zu reproduzieren. Also fang mich da auch sehr gerne ein, wenn das kompletter Quatsch ist.
Nee, nee, klar, das hat man ja immer irgendwie im Hinterkopf, ohne das jetzt belegen zu können. Und ich würde mich auch jetzt nicht mehr so weit aus dem Fenster rauslehnen und behaupten, dass irgendwelche Clubpräsidenten noch Schiedsrichter bezahlen. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass in dem Fußballbusiness, aber wahrscheinlich eher auch in den kleineren Ligen oder in anderen Ländern immer noch auch Dinge zum Vorurteil, aber vielleicht nicht von Clubpräsidenten, sondern von Leuten, die Sportwetten betreiben, da sicherlich Gegebenheiten sind, um diesen Fußball und das Schiedsrichterwesen mit dem Schildbürgerluder zu treiben. Es wird auch sehr intensiv darüber gesprochen, in Italien auf jeden Fall. Das war auch vor dem Spitzenspiel Napoli-Milan, da war die Schiedsrichteransetzung ein Riesenthema. Da wurde Ersato angesetzt, der so auch international gesehen, glaube ich, von den Italienischen aktuell den besten Ruf hat. Aber viele mögen auch seinen Auftreten nicht. Da muss man sagen, der hat das Spitzenspiel exzellent gepfiffen. Und es gibt auch viele gute Schiedsrichter in Italien. Dennoch schwebt das Kalciopoli, was du gesagt hast, schon auch immer wieder mit. Letztens hat er dann Mourinho dann mal wieder. Da ist er dann dafür des Feldes verwiesen, weil er den Sohn eines Schiedsrichters, der früher auch beteiligt wurde, mit einer Geste daran erinnert, dass sein Papa früher auch Anrufe bekommen hat. Und er hat auch gemeint, dich hat Juve wieder geschickt. Ich glaube, klassischer Mourinho, da lässt sich die rote Karte noch nicht verdienen, muss man sagen. Also das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass das grundlegend in dieser Saison auch immer die gleichen Teams bevorteilt oder benachteilt. Und da ist es auch, findest du keinen großen, bemerkbaren Unterschied zwischen Top-Teams und nicht so Top-Teams. Aber es sind in dieser Saison schon wieder sehr viele Entscheidungen, die wirklich für ganz viel Aufsehen gesorgt haben. Wo dann eben auch Journalisten, Spieler, Trainer sagen, also so, dann lieber gar nicht.
Da würde mich mal die Meinung der anderen beiden interessieren. Nils, wie ist denn die Diskussion in La Liga zum VRA?
Oh, guter Punkt. Hätte ich Mario auch noch was gefragt. In La Liga wird die Diskussion mittlerweile von den Vereinen auch in die Öffentlichkeit getragen. Also klar hast du an jedem Spieltag mediale Aufregung, egal ob das in den Tageszeitungen ist, Marke, oder auch Fernsehshows wie Chiringuito, wo sich über die das eine oder andere Faul, Abseits, Elfmeter usw. aufgeregt wird. Aber in La Liga ist es mittlerweile sogar ein Trend, dass die Vereine dann über ihre Social-Media-Kanäle oder auch eben dann natürlich die eigenen Vereins-TV-Sender, Rematri TV, Sevilla TV, sich darüber enorm eschofieren. Da gab es zum Beispiel, hatte Real Sociedad mal eine Spielszene, wo Alexander Isak im Strafraum von Alavesso von hinten geschubst wurde, haben sie die Wiederholung extra getweetet und gezeigt, so mit ein paar Fragezeichen dazu. Valencia hatte in Bernabéu sich benachteiligt gefühlt und den Tweet veröffentlicht, von wegen in Anlehnung an die Serie Casa de Papel. Also Haus des Geldes ist es, ne? Wir dachten, die Robo, die Räube, Raubüberfälle finden nur in Serien hier in Madrid statt. Aber nee, da haben sie sich auch bedrohend gefühlt. Bettis hatte letztens was, Cardi ist einen offenen Brief, an den Liga-Präsidenten geschrieben, von wegen sie fühlen sich benachteiligt und jetzt eben der FC Sevilla am Wochenende so ein Wortspiel gemacht. Varapalo heißt das, also die ersten drei Buchstaben, VAR, das heißt auf Spanisch Rückschlag, das haben sie mit einem Video hinzu. Das heizt die Gemüter ja noch mehr auf und man sieht ja, bei jedem Spiel von Barca oder Real Madrid Athletico immer regt sich irgendwer über irgendwas auf. Eine Polemik ist leider immer, ja, die spanischen Schiedsrichter sind da vielleicht auch nicht die besten, aber es sagt vielleicht auch jede andere Liga von sich. Also es ist schon ein bisschen traurig, wie die Vereine das dann in die Öffentlichkeit tragen und dass da man da wirklich teilweise nach jedem Spieltag irgendwie Schiedsrichterentscheidungen mehr im Vordergrund stehen als vielleicht die tollen Spiele oder wenn auch mal Traumtore fallen oder so. Also ja, das ist gerade kein gutes Bild, was Liga generell da abgibt.
Okay krass, da habe ich ja in ein Wespenest gestorben, das war mir gar nicht klar. Das ist ja wahr.
Und deswegen, da könnte man ja tatsächlich auch wieder die grundlegende Diskussion aufmachen, wenn es dabei bei euch in Anführungszeichen genauso ist, dass es halt wieder –ich ergerne eine Folge über den Fahre im Generellen und seine Sinnhaftigkeit.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich so viel Zeit habe. Ja, aber das ist krass. Wie ist es denn, Alexi, in Ligue 1? Gibt es da auch offene Briefe?
Nicht direkt, aber es gibt auch natürlich viele Beschwerden. Du hast schon vorher Leonardo erwähnt, dass er bei der Niederlage in Nantes 3-1 vor gut zwei Wochen –und da gab es auch Riesendiskussionen über den VAR, aber das ist schon länger. Aber was vor allem vorgeworfen wird, dass man drei bis vier Minuten pro Entscheidung warten muss, sodass man ab und zu Nachspielzeit von zehn bis zwölf Minuten hat. Drei Tage später sieht man in der Champions League jetzt Ratsfatz. Wie kann das sein, dass da dieser Unterschied herrscht? Manche wünschen sich schon, dass es den VAR gar nicht geben würde. Man hat es ja gesehen, letzte Woche in der Europakonferenz League gibt es ja den VAR nicht. Ich glaube, nur im Endspiel, sodass auch da etliche Entscheidungen getroffen wurden, die ungerecht waren mit Elfmetern, mit Abseits-Situationen, insbesondere bei Leicester gegen Rennes. Also da gibt es auch etliche Diskussionen in Frankreich.
Ich sehe schon, es ist ein europaumgreifendes Thema und irgendwie sind es überall die gleichen Themen. Wobei jetzt die Länge der Entscheidungsfindung, das ist jetzt noch ein neuer Aspekt. Das finde ich ganz interessant. Das ist ja was, was sich hier zumindest jetzt in der Bundesliga so ein bisschen eingependelt hat. Wollen wir vielleicht an der Stelle –jetzt überlege ich gerade –jetzt machen wir erst noch Meisterkampf. Ligue 1, Alexis, du hast frei. Das ist einfach. Aber La Liga, Nils, du hast es schon gesagt, ist auch schon entschieden. Hatten wir auch schon in der letzten Ligatur darüber gesprochen. Kannst du was zu den Verfolgern sagen, woran liegt es? Gibt es da neue Entwicklungen? Sevilla hält sich ja immer noch sehr, sehr gut auf Rang 2. Okay, Atletico hast du schon angesprochen, immer wieder mit Problemen. Und über Betis haben wir ja vorhin auch schon gesprochen. Also ich meinte jetzt erst den FC Sevilla.
Nur erst mal kurz gesagt, Real Madrid hat jetzt 10 Punkte Vorsprung. Das bei noch 10 offenen Spieltagen, das wurde noch nie verspielt von einem Tabellenführer, von dem ja Real Madrid ist da auf Kurs. Auch weil eben der FC Sevilla doch immer häufiger part, speziell auch an den letzten Spieltagen. Also jetzt allein von den letzten fünf Auswärtsspielen haben sie immer nur die Punkte geteilt. Da jetzt auch nicht viele Gegentore kassiert, 3 zu 3 Tore, aber da ist immer irgendwie der Wurm drin. Sevilla ist sehr minimalistisch mittlerweile. Die Taktik ist aktuell mehr Platz halten, statt wirklich real anzugreifen, unter Druck zu setzen. Es kommt auch noch jetzt Anfang April Israel auch noch zu Gast beim FC Sevilla. Aber auch da ist Lopetegui kein Mann, der irgendwie groß Top-Spiele für sich entscheidet, wo dann auch manchmal die Mannschaft zu motiviert ist, überdreht, Disziplinprobleme bekommt. Also Sevilla ist eher ein bisschen wackelig da auf dem zweiten Platz dran. Jetzt wurde FC Barcelona wieder zu Fahrt aufgenommen. Die haben jetzt von den letzten zehn Spieltagen keins verloren, sieben gewonnen. Die Offensive läuft ziemlich rund. Die haben eine hohe Effektivität wieder dadurch, dass sie im Winter Transfermarkt Ferran Torres, Aubameyang und so weiter geholt haben. Also da läuft wieder einiges rund. Deswegen ist Barca nur noch fünf Punkte hinter Sevilla. Sie hat sogar noch ein Spiel in der Rückhand gegen Rayo Vallecano, ein Nachholspiel. Die sind auch nicht mehr gut drauf, von dem her sind es vielleicht nur noch zwei Punkte hinter Sevilla. Und Atletico, der Meister, ja, irgendwie, ich hatte schon gesagt, die schwächste Saison bisher unter Simeone mit aktuell nur was sind es 51 Punkten. Der zweitschwächste Wert war mal 2017, da waren es noch 55 Punkte zum gleichen Zeitpunkt. Vor einem Jahr waren es 66 Punkte nach 28 Spieltagen. Also da ist auch, war lange der Wurm drin. Mittlerweile hat man sich gefangen. Das war ja auch jetzt gegen Manchester United eigentlich ein ziemlich gutes Spiel. Am Ende kassiert man dann doch noch den Ausgleich. Aber ja, man kann sagen, die Top 4 von der Vorsaison sind da wieder beieinander und ordnen sich mehr oder weniger ein bisschen wieder an, auch wenn Real Madrid erster bleiben wird.
Und wie bewertest du das dann, dass da Sevilla mit drin hängt, dass es dann aber keine Überraschung mehr, dass die auf Platz 2 sind und weil sie jetzt vielleicht noch abgefangen werden? Von Außenbetracht hätte ich gesagt, also gerade die Abwehrleistung ist ja immens mit nur zwei Niederlagen bei 19 Gegentreffern. Probleme sind halt, du hast ja angesprochen, die unentschieden.
Genau, also 19 Gegentore sind ja auch die beste Defensive. Das ist jetzt natürlich auch Meckern auf hohem Niveau. Aber mit dem Kader, den Lupe Di hat, wäre eigentlich schon mehr drin. Und so gut ist Riyama tritt jetzt auch nicht. Das war jetzt auch gestern auf Mallorca wieder 0-0 zur Pause. Sehr überschaubar und dann eben wieder ein bisschen Effizienz. Vinicius Benzema also für Sevilla wäre da schon auch ein bisschen mehr drin gewesen oder ist natürlich theoretisch immer noch. Man hat ja so gesehen auch so die zweitbeste Saison der Vereinsgeschichte mit jetzt 56 Punkten aus der 28 Spieltagen. Das ist alles voll in Ordnung. Nur eben viele haben das Gefühl, dass die Mannschaft noch mehr könnte und dann eben doch manchmal zu minimalistisch, zu vorsichtig ins Spiel geht. Erst mal Ballbesitz, Spielkontrolle und dann irgendwie auf den Fehler vorne lauern, ist jetzt auch nicht, dass die regelmäßig 15 Abschlüsse oder so haben. Das ist schon auch eher alles ein bisschen kontrollierter und sie beugen sich selten, wenn sie mal zurückliegen. Also da gab es noch keine einzige erfolgreiche Remontada, sprich noch kein Spiel, haben sie zu einem Sieg gedreht in der Liga. Immer mal ein Unentschieden, wie jetzt auch gegen Rayo Vallecano, aber irgendwie wird man das Gefühl einfach nicht los. Sevilla hätte in dieser Saison, wo auch real nicht so galaktisch ist, wäre da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr drin.
Sevilla übrigens die zweitbeste Abwehr europaweit. Auf den ersten vier Plätzen drei Mannschaften aus der Premier League. Manchester City 18 Gegentreffer, Sevilla und Chelsea 19, Liverpool 20 Gegentreffer. Das waren noch Zeiten, als die Abwehrreihen nicht so gut waren in der Premier League. Das liegt jetzt schon eine Weile zurück. Und dann haben wir ja ein richtiges Meisterschaftsrennen, nämlich bei Mario. Der kann nur leise lächeln, wenn es heißt, ja hier ist schon alles entschieden. PSG macht das und Real macht das. Mario, in der Serie A ist ja sogar Juve auf einmal wieder in der Verlosung mit drin. Was ist da denn jetzt schon wieder los?
Ja, ich musste letztens drüber lachen, da habe ich mich, glaube ich, auch mit Christian drüber unterhalten, weil ich vor der Saison gesagt habe, dass Juve ganz deutlich wieder Meister wird und muss dann da zwischenzeitlich Großabbitte leisten. Als er mich letztens noch mal gefragt hatte, was denn jetzt mein Meistertipp wäre und ob wir es dann bei Inter bleiben, da habe ich gemeint, irgendwie will ich jetzt fast sagen, es macht doch wieder Juve. Wobei, die sind jetzt aktuell sieben hinter Milan. Aber sie gewinnen halt alle Spiele gerade. Das ist nicht so, dass mich das bei Juve überzeugen würde, was sie machen, aber sie gewinnen einfach immer wieder. Und das ist das, was bei Juve einem so viel Angst machen sollte, wenn man jetzt mit den anderen hält oder wenn man einfach mal will, dass Juve nicht Meister wird. Und dann ist das immer ein Zeichen dafür, dass auf einmal wieder Juve-Fußball gespielt wird. Und das hat Allegri vollkommen zu Recht auch gesagt, weil zuletzt dann auch natürlich viele Fans trotzdem kritisiert haben, wie phlegmatisch teilweise gespielt wird, hat er gemeint. Das war früher auch schon immer so, dass wir ganz viele Spiele 1-0 und nicht so überzeugend gewonnen haben, aber wir gewinnen halt. Und das machen sie gerade. Sie haben eben im Winter mit Vlaović eingeholt, der ihm jetzt auch wieder Tore gibt, was sie halt in den letzten Jahren auch immer nochmal mit CR7 hatten einfach. Sie haben leider aber trotzdem auch viel Verletzungspech im Mittelfeld. Sakaria dann direkt wieder ausgefallen in der Defensive, immer wieder WW-chen. Da kannst du natürlich auch sagen, das ist einfach dann immer noch ein nicht gut stattfindender Umbruch, den sie da angeschoben haben, wenn du dich weiter darauf verlässt, dass irgendwie zwei 40-Jährige dann die ganze Saison der Innenverteidigung funktionieren sollen. Die Licht ist weitestgehend wirklich überragend. Deswegen würde ich sie auf jeden Fall noch nicht abschreiben. Und vorne geht es ja noch enger zur Sache. Milan hat jetzt 63, sind drei Punkte vor Napoli, da sie eben das Spitzenspiel gewonnen haben. Das hat ihnen auf jeden Fall einen richtigen Push gegeben, als sie Maradona gewonnen haben. Und Inter hat ein bisschen abreißen lassen, wobei dazu auch dazu gehört, dass die mit einem Spiel in der Hinterhand, auch noch, wenn sie da drei Zähler holen, wieder auf einen Punkt ran wären an Milan.
Also hat ja eigentlich die Serie A das, was man sich wünscht. Ein richtig enges Titelrennen. Und es war ja jetzt ja die ganze Saison über, schon zwischenzeitlich. Aber das weiß ich noch. Ich glaube, das war Marios Seuke, glaube ich, hat gesagt, dass Inter auf Jahre hinweg die Meisterschaft nicht mehr zu nehmen sein wird. Er hat Inter als das neue Juve bezeichnet. Also ist er eigentlich gerade so mit die spannendste Liga Europas, oder?
Ich finde, das kann man so deutlich sagen. Also und das, was Marios gesagt hat, das würde ich auch eigentlich immer noch unterschreiben, aber sie vercoachens gerade tatsächlich ein bisschen. Da muss man wirklich in Sargi in die Pflicht nehmen, denn sie haben in der Breite den besten Kater. Aber er rotiert zu wenig. Und er hat vor allem im ersten Drittel der Saison auch schon zu wenig rotiert. Und das ist auch ein Phänomen, das bei ihm in den letzten Jahren immer wieder aufgetaucht ist. Klar muss man sagen, da hat er Lazio trainiert. Das ist dann vielleicht auch bei einer Mannschaft, die qualitativ irgendwo fünf bis zehn Prozentpunkte einfach auch weniger da hat. Vielleicht auch mal in Ordnung, dass du hinten raus dann noch die Champions League verspielst und dann vielleicht wieder fünfter wirst, so in die Richtung. Aber bei Inter hätte er es jetzt eigentlich haben können und hat aber nicht rotiert zwischenzeitlich. Immer wieder die gleichen und du hast dann schon auch Partien dabei gehabt, wo du gemerkt hast, dass ein Paar jetzt dann überspielt. Und dann fällt auf einmal wieder Prusovic in der Zentrale weg. Merkst dann, wenn ein Barell nicht die komplette Energie hat, die er für sein Spiel auch braucht, dann geht ihnen da was ab, auch in der Qualität. Und die haben, würde ich sogar fast sagen, von den drei da oben, hat Inter das ekelhafteste Schlussprogramm. Die spielen auch noch gegen Juve. Am zweitschwersten, würde ich sagen, hat es Napoli. Die haben jetzt aber ihre erste Aufgabe gegen Hellas, das auch eben so ein Team ist, das super unangenehm ist, gut gelöst. Und es ist eh gut möglich, dass diese Teams dieser Kategorie, so Florenz, Hellas, vielleicht auch Udinese, die sich gerade aus dem Abstiegskampf verabschiedet haben, aber die gute Einzelspieler haben, aber schon immer so eine Mannschaft waren, die auch für die Großen unangenehm zu bespielen sind. Also da musst du dann erstmal das eine Tor machen. Und wenn sie auch noch alle haben, das ist eben jetzt das, was hinter am Wochenende passiert ist beim FC Turin. Der Mannschaft von Ivan Juric, der da in seiner ersten Saison, letztes Jahr Turino fast abgestiegen und jetzt hat er da was etabliert, was schon vielen Top-Klubs Kopfzerbrechen bereitet hat. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die immer eklig vorne drauf geht und du kaum dein Spiel hinten richtig geordnet aufbauen kannst und eben auch über viel, viel Physis. Mit Bremen einen Innenverteidiger, der wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Jahren irgendwo auch noch bei einem Top-Klub spielen wird. Das sind jetzt diese Teams, die stehen irgendwo zwischen Platz 8 und Platz 12. Aber bereiten gerade vielen von den Teams da oben Probleme, wenn sie die so intensiv bespielen und die so langsam auch mit der bislang immer noch vorhandenen Dreifachbelastung dann irgendwann auch an ihre Limits kommen. Und das muss man Ihnen ganz klar vorwerfen, dass er da den gegebenen Kater nicht ausgenutzt hat.
Okay, das ist der Meisterschaftskampf. Dann lasst uns abschließend noch auf den Abstiegskampf blicken. Alexi, es gab eine Push-Meldung der L'Equipe am Wochenende, dass Jérôme D'Aubaudot nicht mehr die schlechteste Abwehr Europas hätte. Große Freude, denn die Spielvereinigung Kräuter-Viert hat es geschafft, mit dem 1-6 gegen Rasenball-Sport Leipzig bei 70 Gegentreffern zu stehen. Baudot hat 68 Gegentreffer, ist aber dennoch noch Tabellenletzter mit vier Punkten Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz. Wie schätzt du die Situation dort ein und generell im Abstiegskampf in der Liga?
Für Baudot wird es schwer, weil man schon sehr lange hinten steht. Und man hat jetzt einen Trainerwechsel gemacht vor drei Wochen, womöglich zu spät, mit der Entlassung von Petkovic, dem ehemaligen Schweizer Nationaltrainer und David Guillaume, der mit kleineren Mannschaften klarkam. Baudot ist schon ein Verein, der polarisiert. Das ist eine der größten Clubs in der Geschichte des Vereinsfußballs in Frankreich. Mehrfach eben hat es Finale im Europa-Pokal gewesen, Finale im UEFA Cup gegen die Bayern damals 1996. Unter anderem Meister noch gewesen vor zwölf Jahren. Mit Laurent Blanc als Trainer. Und danach noch die Bayern und Juve hinter sich gelassen in der Gruppenphase 2009, 2010. Seitdem ging es städtisch bergab. Es tut mir leid, Mario, aber wie wir da reden, wie deine Freunde aus Hamburg oder Schalke 04, Mannschaften, die schlecht arbeiten, bekommen irgendwann die Quittung. Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass es hier unten steht. Man hat sich zwei, drei Mal in den letzten Jahren gerade noch gerettet oder retten können. Aber das Schlimme, das Schlimmste ist bei Girondin, sollte man tatsächlich sportlich absteigen, dann droht sogar die dritte Liga. Denn finanziell steht der Girondin vor dem Kollaps. Und wenn Girondin also absteigt, wird man womöglich nicht in der zweiten Liga, die kommende Saison mehr gehen, sondern in der dritten oder vierten Liga. Und das wäre natürlich das Aus erstmal, weil es gibt kein klares Konzert wie eines in Salzburg, wo man ja vor zehn Jahren in der fünften Liga stand und jetzt fast an die Champions League-Tür klopft, weil man da ein klares Konzert und richtig mit viel Struktur und viel Kreativität und Professionalismus gearbeitet hat im Namen von Marc Geller, der ehemalige graushoher Stürmer. Einen solchen Typen hast du gerade in Bordeaux nicht. Und deswegen droht erst einmal der Chaos und der Chaos-Schlag von Girondin. Aber wie gesagt, das wäre alles andere als unverdient, weil man einfach schlecht, sehr schlecht gearbeitet hat die letzten Jahre. Ich wusste nicht, wie Girona sich noch retten könnte in dieser Saison. Weil auch die anderen kleineren wie Lorient, wie Troyes, wie Clermont, wie Metz, die sind ein bisschen konstanter. Und die kennen solche Abschließ-Kampfspiele, entscheidende Spiele. Und auch wenn man richtig eingekauft hat jetzt im Winter bei Girona, mit Marcela, zwei Bundesligaspieler, um den Abschließ zu vermeiden, scheint mir die Lage rufnungslos zu sein bei Girona. Im Gegensatz zu Saint-Etienne. Immer noch für ein paar Wochen Rekordmeister Frankreichs, denn Peugeot wird diesen Rektor vom 10. Meistertitel einstellen. Saint-Etienne war auch lange vor, mit der Hinrunde. Da hat man den Trainerwechsel vorangetrieben vor den letzten zweieinhalb Monaten. Das war noch der richtige Zeitpunkt. Seitdem ist Saint-Etienne wieder auf einem guten Weg. Man hat jetzt die zwei letzten Plätze verlassen. Man ist jetzt auf einem guten Weg, zuletzt 0-0 beim amtierenden Meister Lelö gespielt. Man spürt bei Saint-Etienne eine gewisse Euphorie, weil auch das Pferd und Iber ausverkauft ist. Auswärts die Fans voll mitmachen und diese Mannschaft, die keinen anderen unterstützen. Das ist wirklich ein Mythos, dieses Saint-Etienne in Frankreich. War auch mal im Europapokalfinale, damals gegen die Bayern, auch Mitte der 70er Europapokalf des Landesmeisters. Also, es wäre schön, wenn beide sich noch retten könnten. Aber ich glaube, Bordowicz erwischen und Saint-Etienne wird aber in der kommenden Saison immer noch in der Elite mitmachen dürfen.
Ich habe mal von Neven Subotic, glaube ich, in einem Podcast gehört, dass er Saint-Etienne ein bisschen mit Schalke 04 verglichen hat, wegen auch ähnlicher Industrie vor Ort und eben wegen der ecstatischen Fans. Ich weiß nicht, ob ein ex-BVB-Spieler überhaupt irgendwas mit Schalke vergleichen kann und das positiv meinen darf. Aber Subotic war schon immer ein bisschen anderer Profi. Wie weit, würdest du sagen, geht die Abstiegszone in der Ligue 1? Also wenn man sich das punktemäßig anguckt, Bordow 22, Metz 23, Saint-Etienne 26 und dann Lorient 27, Clermont und Troyes mit 28 und dann Angers 29. Das heißt, die liegen so innerhalb von sieben Punkten. Sind das auch die Mannschaften, die es untereinander ausspielt? Weil gerade bei Angers, da sieht es ja, wenn ich so formtechnisch draufgucke, nicht so gut aus mit sechs Niederlagen in sechs Spielen. Alle anderen haben mit Ausnahme der letzten beiden irgendwann wenigstens mal gewonnen in den letzten Partien.
Also erstmal will ich dich gerne gratulieren, weil du bist einer der wenigen Deutschen, die Angers richtig aussprechen. Bei den meisten sogar Kommentatoren immer noch nicht der Fall, im Jahr 2022, aber ist halt leider so. Wieder klammert zu, Angers hat sogar nicht neunmal verloren in Folge, dachte ich zumindest. Also auf jeden Fall eine Mannschaft, die in der Hinrunde gar nichts mit dem Ampelschusskampf zu tun hatte, aber auf einmal mitten drin steckt sogar die Legende. Guiru, 88, hat länger mit dem Angers-Trainer Jérôme Batic telefoniert, um ihm ein paar Ralschläge zu geben. Guiru war 45 Jahre Trainer bei Auxerre, pausenlos damals. Aber das hat auch nichts gebracht. Angers hat wieder verloren an diesem Wochenende gegen Reims. Wenn die Spirale weitergeht, dann wird es doch noch Angers. Zumindest für die beiden Relegation-Spiele Ende Mai. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass Mannschaften wie Lorient und Troyes eigentlich gewohnt sind, solche Spiele zu bestreiten, die die wenigsten Probleme haben werden. Darüber haben wir schon thematisiert. Das antwortieren wir auch. Metz ist schon sehr lange da unten. Man hat sehr viele Spieler im Kader, die beim Afrika-Cup dabei waren. Auch der Trainer wurde jetzt für zehn Spiele gespielt, weil er wieder ausgepflegt ist. Der Friedrich Antonetti. Für zehn Spiele?
Was hat er denn gemacht?
Er ist ausgepflegt, wie immer. Er kommt aus Korsika, hat sehr viel Temperament. Das ist auch nicht einfach für ihn da in Nottingen. Aber es kam zu Rangeleien mit dem Sporsdirektor von Lille an der Bank. Das war wirklich viel zu mulch. Er ist ein Wiederholungstäter für den Rigauntonetti.
Immer wieder so ist es in der Liga. Man denkt hier, mit Felix Magath bei Hertha würden die lustigen Geschichten geschrieben. Aber sich einfach mal zehn Spiele Sparer einzufangen im Abstiegskampf. Na gut, jede Liga hat ihr eigenes Ding. Welches Ding hat denn La Liga im Abstiegskampf, Nils?
Ja, das Ding, da wo ich gesagt habe, der erste von der Situation, er hat sich noch nie die Meisterschaft nehmen lassen. So düster sieht es dann bei UD Levante aus. Die haben sich jetzt mit 19 Punkten aus 28 Partien. Bei so einer Situation ist die Mannschaft immer abgestiegen, konnte sich noch nie retten. Da war ich eben überrascht, als du gesagt hast, Föhrt 70 Gegentore. Ja, in der Liga ist die Schießbude auch Levante. Die haben nur 55 Gegentore, aber bei denen ist irgendwie der Wurm drin. Die hatten einen neuen Rekord aufgestellt in der Liga. Sprich, das waren dann mal Saisonübergreifend. Was sind 27 Spieltage ohne Sieg? Das ist zuletzt mal Gijon im Jahr 1998 gelungen. Damals nur 24 Spieltage, also irgendwie. Die haben die Hinrunde extrem verbockt. Und man dachte eigentlich, das ist ja so, Levante ist eigentlich ein typisches Mittelfeld-Team im Vorjahr 14, da vor dem Jahr zwölfter geworden, dass sie sich dann in der Rückrunde einfach fangen. Haben auch zweimal schon den Trainer gewechselt. Unter Pereira und Paco Lopez hat es nicht mehr geklappt. Jetzt ist Alessio Liski vom Interimstrainer zum Cheftrainer geworden, aber irgendwie immer noch ist da der Wurm drin, auch wenn man mal den Meister Athletico geärgert hat, aber das ist irgendwie so ein typisches Ding von denen, das machen die gerne mal. Irgendwie kommen die nicht richtig in die Spur und es sieht da einfach düster aus, dass Levante da in die zweite Liga muss, obwohl sie sich ja eigentlich auch ganz gut verstärkt haben. Roberto Soldado vom FC Granada verpflichtet und Granada dann genauso ein Problem gebracht. Die sind immerhin viertletzter, halten sie sich so mit einem Punkt davor, hatten ja auch lange gute Zeiten in der Liga erlebt unter ihrem alten Trainer Martinez, der ist dann freiwillig gegangen, genauso wie Soldado. Seitdem sind die jetzt ziemlich abgestürzt. Da sieht es böse aus. Alaves ist eine extrem harmlose Mannschaft mit nur 21 Treffern. Also da hat auch Föhrtmeer mit 24. Die Hälfte von diesen Toren trägt José Lu auf seinen Schultern, ehemaliger Bundesligaspieler. Aber auch da weiß keiner sonst, wie man Tore schießen soll. Und auch deswegen sieht es für Alaves ziemlich düster aus. Dann gibt es noch den FC Kadis. Die sind ja auch vorletztes Jahr aufgestiegen, haben dann La Liga gerockt mit ihrer sehr passiven Spielweise. Die haben im Schnitt 39 Prozent Ball mit die schlechtesten Passwerte, aber einfach sind ein Defensivballwerk. Und das hat letztes Jahr ziemlich gut geklappt. Man hat Reha Madrid geschlagen, Basalt geärgert und vieles mehr. Und jetzt ist man auch mehr und mehr in den Abstiegsstrudel reingeraten. Aktuell 18. Ich habe noch Hoffnung, dass sie irgendwie auch erst den Trainerwechsel haben, dass das noch was werden kann. Bei Granada aktuell auch so schlecht ist. Ich glaube, jetzt auch zehn Spiele haben die nicht mehr gewonnen, trotz Trainerwechsels. Also Levante aller Besten sind fast sicher schon weg, auch wenn natürlich noch zehn Spieltage offen sind. 30 Punkte, bla. Aber Mallorca, Hitafel, irgendwo halten sich El Chata auch einen erfolgreichen Trainerwechsel. Ansonsten ist da jetzt gar nicht so viel extrem überraschend. Überraschend war vielleicht natürlich, dass Rayo Vallecano so eine sensationelle Hinrunde hatte. Die waren ja zwischenzeitlich mal 6. und auch mal 5. zwischendurch. Die sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen durchgereicht auf Platz 13, aber zehren einfach noch von ihrem Punktepolster und haben da noch ihre 8-Punkte-Vorsprung.
Also wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, verwundert mich das jetzt total, dass du sagst, das ist alles schon so entschieden, als ich dieses Abstiegskampf-Thema aufgemacht habe. Da habe ich unter anderem eben in La Liga gesehen. Also wir haben Hitafel, die haben in den letzten sechs Spielen einmal gewonnen und ansonsten drei Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Wir haben Mallorca, die haben in den letzten sechs Spielen fünf Mal verloren. Wir haben Granada, die haben in den letzten sechs Spielen fünf Mal verloren und einen Unentschieden geholt. Aber ganz hinten, Cadiz hat gewonnen in den letzten sechs Spielen einmal und drei Unentschieden. Alaves hat einmal gewonnen, zwei Unentschieden. Und Levante hast du ja auch angesprochen, die haben ja jetzt dann angefangen, Punkte zusammen. Ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, da kommt gerade was in Bewegung. Aber hört sich dann bei dir gar nicht so an.
Die haben irgendwie den Knacks immer noch weg. Und jetzt droht wohl auch ihr Top-Stürmer Morales langfristig verletzungsbedingt auszufallen. Also irgendwie, mir fehlte einfach die Hoffnung im Winter-Transfer-Fenster habe ich auch gedacht, jetzt legen sie noch mal los. Aber dank des Salary-Caps in der Liga konnten die jetzt da auch nicht so extrem tätig werden. Wie gesagt, Alaves hat auch der Trainerwechsel nicht funktioniert mit Mendy Liban, einem alten Abstiegsexperten, der kam ja von Eber. Da weiß keiner, wo das Tor wirklich steht. Caddys, die können das schaffen, weil Granada auch so schlecht drauf ist. Mallorca war gestern auch eigentlich nicht katastrophal. Die haben in Real Madrid einen sehr guten Kampf geliefert, aber auch teilweise zu viel gekämpft, zu hart gekämpft, zu viele Fouls. Die haben auch schon 48 Gegentore, die zweitschlechteste Defensive der Liga. Aber Retafe dafür ist ein Beispiel für den erfolgreichen Trainerwechsel. Dort hatte man ja im Sommer Bordalas verloren, der ist jetzt bei Valencia. Dann kam Michel, ehemalige Real-Legende, auch Retafe-Legende. Da hat es absoluter Fehlstart gehabt. Aber eben unter Quique Sanches Flores durchaus einige Heimsiege geholt. Auch Real Madrid mit 1-0 geschlagen. Nur irgendwie sind die einzige Mannschaft noch ohne Auswärtssieger. Aber das ist irgendwo noch verschmerzbar. Also die haben auch diese Mentalität, den Kampf. Die haben auch diese... Die kämpfen einfach enorm. Enes Ünal spielt eine herausragende Rückrunde. Ist da fast auf Ballon d'Or-Kurs. Fast schon so witzelt man ein bisschen in der Liga. Deswegen ist da jetzt noch eher die Hoffnung da, als jetzt, wie gesagt, bei einer Vespa oder Levante.
Na gut, ich akzeptiere das auch, wenn du das so sagst. Dann wird das schon so sein. Bleibt nur noch abschließend die Frage, Mario. Wie ist es in der Serie A? Kannst du mir da jetzt so einen richtig spannenden Abstiegskampf verkaufen? Noch zusätzlich zum Meisterschaftskampf? Wäre fast schon zu viel.
Na, richtig spannend, nicht interessant, finde ich ihn schon. Das ist auch so ein bisschen wie in der Liga. So große Überraschungen sind nicht dabei. Es ist wieder mal eine Saison, wo du sagen kannst, dass es eigentlich immer zwei von drei Aufsteigern erwischt. Empoli hat es wirklich insofern hinbekommen, glaube ich, dass die die Klasse halten werden. Die haben auch in der Hinrunde sehr, sehr gut gespielt. Man kann es vielleicht jetzt da mit Valle Cano, was Nils gerade gesagt hat, vergleichen. Die haben eine Zeit lang sehr viele Spiele, sehr viele Punkte geholt. Gab, wo sie dann auch noch mal auch große geschlagen haben, hatten im Dezember noch in Napoli gewonnen. Und dann ist das wirklich am 12. Dezember gerade noch mal nachgeschaut. Der letzte Dreier gewesen von Empoli. Und seitdem ganz viel unentschieden, ganz viel verloren. Und dennoch stehen sie jetzt halt mit 32 Zählern. Zehn vom ersten Abstiegsrang. Die ziehen eben auch davon. Und das wird für die auf jeden Fall reichen. Denn ich würde mal sagen, die Abstiegszone fängt frühestens bei Platz 15 bei Las Bezia an. Die haben 29 Punkte. Die haben am Wochenende einen ganz, ganz wichtigen Sieg eingefahren. Weil sonst wäre es da für Thiago Mutter und das Team schon auch nochmal sehr, sehr schwierig geworden, dass die zweite Saison für die da oben jetzt in Folge –und da haben ihnen auch viele prophezeit –dass es schwierig wird. Aber selbst mit diesen 29 Punkten könnte es eben reichen, weil dann einer der anderen Aufsteiger, Venezia, ganz eben im Vergleich zu Empoli nicht regelmäßig genug auch dreifach gepunktet hat. Also die haben auch wirklich gut mitgespielt. Die haben auch mal die Roma geschlagen. Die haben einen Unentschieden gegen Juve gespielt. Aber ganz viele von diesen Spielen, wo man vielleicht auch hätte mal irgendwie knapp gewinnen können, haben sie dann entweder nur Unentschieden gespielt oder sogar auch verloren. Jetzt erst gestern wieder auch nur 1-0 mitgespielt, aber dann eben gegen Lazio verloren. Und so wird es leider für Venezia so coolster ist mit dem Stadion. Und ja, die Trikots sind auch schön. Man hat schon mal davon gehört, dass es ja wahrscheinlich kaum durchs Dorf getrieben worden ist, dass die schöne Trikots haben. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr reichen. Und deswegen glaube ich sogar, dass es für die Teams davor wie Kajarife, die es vor der Winterpause mal ganz schlecht aussah, die aber qualitativ schon einen besseren Kader haben als die da unten, als die dann irgendwann mal angefangen haben, endlich auch ein paar Spielchen zu gewinnen. Dann kamen sie da auch auf diesem kleinen Stadion da bei ihnen auf der Insel. Es ist schon auch eine feurige Atmosphäre, haben auch viele Spieler, die da so vorangehen. Haben auch auf Qualitätsebene mit Schau Petro einen, der sehr gut Fußball spielen kann. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass die sich sogar noch auch wieder den Klassenerhalt holen werden, auch wenn es punktetechnisch jetzt nur drei auf Venezia sind. Aber mir fehlt so ein bisschen die Fantasie dafür, wo Venezia jetzt noch oft Dreier holen soll. Und dahinter wird es eben für Genoa und Salernitana ganz, ganz düster. Salernitana ist auch so ein bisschen das Fürth Italiens, würde ich mal sagen. Die spielen inzwischen auch genau wie das Gleblatt in der Rückrunde echt ganz oft gut mit. Und da ist auch eine prächtige Stimmung, die Mannschaft lebt auch. Das heißt, dass ja auch da in Salerno Süditalien, man guckt sich gerne Spiele an, weil die Fans immer noch hinter dem Team stehen. Und sie waren jetzt auch mehrfach dran, mal ein Spiel zu gewinnen, spielen dann aber auch nur unentschieden. Aber hatten auch eigentlich einen erfolgreichen Trainerwechsel jetzt. Da ist jetzt wieder Davide Nicola. Und da baut man was auf, wo man, glaube ich, nächste Saison wieder zu den Aufstiegsfavoriten gehört. Lustigerweise haben die in der Winterpause so viele neuen Spieler geholt, sogar noch einen neuen Torwart. Die konnten in der Zwischenzeit eine komplett neue Elf aufstellen und haben halt ganz viele so gestandene Profis geholt, die ein paar Jahre auf dem Buckel hatten und hat dann funktioniert. Das hat man vor der Saison nur mit Ribéry machen wollen. Da war das aber auch, glaube ich, mehr Marketinggag als sonst was, weil der war dann auch wieder, wie es von ihm jetzt auch in den letzten Jahren immer mal wieder der Fall war, zu häufig verletzt. Und da haben sie viel zu früh zu deutlich abreißen lassen. Was ich noch sehr, sehr interessant finde, ist der CFC aus Genua, weil ja Samp auch noch so ein bisschen drin ist. Also es sind die letzten Jahre eh immer sehr schwere Jahre für die Hafenstadt, die ja auch traditionell bedingt eine große Rolle im italienischen Fußball spielt. Und beim CFC ist es auf jeden Fall auch so ein Jahr des Umbruchs gewesen. Die haben eine sehr, sehr gute Jugendarbeit eigentlich, die auch mal den Titel geholt in der Primavera, also da, wo die U19 spielt, und haben aber am Anfang der Saison noch, dann hatten die auch einen Besitzerwechsel. Ihr Preziosi, der Spielwahn, Mogul, der hat jetzt den Verein abgegeben an amerikanische Investoren und davor war natürlich da auch immer viel Unruhe. Also da wirklich die italienischen Klischees, dann lieber den Trainer Zehmer entlassen und dann einmal der Balladini und wie sie alle heißen, entlassen, wieder da, entlassen, wieder da, teilweise zweimal in einer Saison. Also da ist es dann natürlich auch schwer, irgendwie seriös sportlich zu arbeiten. Und damit haben sie aber jetzt angefangen. Sie haben ja Spors als Sportdirektor geholt. Und Blesin …Der Sporsdirektor. Wenn ich so einen liegen lasse, dann bin ich sehr dankbar dafür, dass du ihn noch einnetzt. Und na, mit Blesin eben einen jungen, spannenden Trainer, der wirklich im Vergleich, man kann sich jetzt auch gut Genuaspiele anschauen, die verteidigen nach vorne. Das ist alles sehr temporeich, sehr aggressiv. Das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Rabaschule, in der er auch sein Trainerhandwerk gelernt hat. Aber das sind alles Dinge, wo man sieht, dass es schon auch funktionieren könnte. Aber da bin ich auch jetzt wieder an diesem Punkt, wo dir ja unten eben halt die Unentschieden nicht reichen. Du musst zwischendurch mal ein Spiel gewinnen. Und beim Thema Unentschieden, ich weiß, das hast du dir wahrscheinlich auch davor angeguckt, der hat noch kein Spiel verloren, seit er da ist. Das sind sieben. Er hat siebenmal Unentschieden gespielt. Er hat siebenmal Unentschieden gespielt.
Mit zwei zu zwei Toren. Da waren fünf 0-0-Spieler mit dabei. Das ist so ganz alte Hyp Stevens Masterclass, obwohl der Fußball nichts mit Hyp Stevens zu tun hat. Also man kann es auch komplett anders erreichen.
Also vom Ergebnis her ja. Und da sind wir aber auch wieder am Punkt. Es ist vorne, eben da setzen sie auch, haben die Boa aus Österreich, von Graz geholt. Aber die letzten 10, 15 Prozent Qualität fehlen dann vorne auch. Dann hätte ich dann doch lieber wahrscheinlich da noch einen 35-jährigen Haudegen im Sturm gehabt, der den zumindest mal in der 90. eins einnetzt und der vielleicht Abstiegskampf kann. Das kann man ihm vielleicht vorwerfen. Und irgendwie ist es dann, wenn du die Entwicklung jetzt so siehst, fast ein bisschen schade. Aber es sind eben sechs Punkte Rückstand auf Karriere. Und wahrscheinlich der Zug ist abgefahren, dass man jetzt auf Unentschieden setzen sollte, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es jetzt aber, wenn sie jetzt noch mal vier- oder fünfmal Unentschieden spielen, ist es jetzt auf jeden Fall schon ein Trainer-Startrekord. Und vermutlich die drei, die gerade unten stehen. Ich habe gesagt, das fängt ab Spezia an, aber mir fehlt, wie gesagt, die Fantasie beim Aufsteiger Venezia, dass sie noch so viele Punkte holen. Und gegnertechnisch wird es für alle jetzt auch nicht unbedingt leichter.
Na gut, Genua war tatsächlich so ein bisschen der Anlass, warum ich auch mal über den Abstiegskampf reden wollte. Und wenn die Hörerinnen und Hörer noch etwas Lektüre suchen, wenn ihr mit der unendlichen Geschichte von Michael Ende durch seid, dann geht doch einfach auf transfermarkt.de und lest euch einfach die kompletten Wechsel zu und Abgänge von Genua durch. Da solltet ihr auch die Zeit rumbringen bis zur nächsten Ligatur. So ungefähr wahrscheinlich. Wenn ihr euch beeilt, kriegt ihr das gerade noch hin. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Es hat wie immer große Freude gemacht. War sehr schön. Danke an Alexis Menuge. Das freut mich. Danke an Nils Kern. Es ist halt wirklich so. Und herzlichen Dank an Mario Rieker. Danke dir, Mario. Ich freue mich auf Feedback von euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Nächste Woche gibt es wahrscheinlich auch einen Kurzpass. Alles noch nicht so genau geplant. Aber eventuell sprechen wir da dann über die 2. Männerbundesliga hier in Deutschland. In diesem Sinne, hört den Rasenfunk, unterstützt ihn finanziell. rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr das tun könnt. Und dann bleiben wir werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei und hören uns auch in der näheren Zukunft wieder. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, macht es gut und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk.